The sections I outlined above
are things that everyone should include
in their resume.
But what about those of you who
are making a career change or
are new to the field or
want to make your personality shine.
If you are making a career change for
example,
we recommend that you include a summary
statement below your heading section.
What is a summary statement?
It is a two to three sentence statement
that functions as resume elevator pitch.
It helps to frame your professional
resume, speaks to your passions,
strengths, and current career.
If this sounds like your background,
draft a summary statement
in your master resume.
You can customize this later
in your one page resume.
New to the field and
have limited experience.
Be sure to include all the projects and
course work you've completed at Udacity.
Even if you didn't do this at a job,
these examples will provide
evidence of your work.
Finally, want to show your personality?
If you feel like your resume
is lacking in interest and
you have ample space, include
information about any achievements,
activities, organizations,
and relevant hobbies.
This helps humanize your resume, and
depending on the company you're applying
to, can convey your culture fit.
Before moving on to the next step,
fill out this section in your
master resume spreadsheet.